hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the section of
the thousand and one goals found in part
one of the spoke zarathustra Friedrich
Nietzsche is going to send out a sort of
perspective or if you like piece of the
theory on values and valuation and we
should be clear that the language here
although it's often translated in terms
of values Nietzsche is actually using
the word good or good right and he's
talking about sort of Ayrton as in
ascribing value he's talking instead
about we could say holding something
dear Jetson right
- Schatz is my treasure it's a term that
people use for in you know endearment
you might call a lover or a friend or
somebody else like that who's very very
close to you it's not somebody that you
you treasure right and what he's saying
here might seem a little bit out of
accord with what he tells us in other
works about values and valuation for
example in the genealogy of morals but I
think if we keep in mind that Nietzsche
although he has Aerith who stir talking
about
all different people's he's not actually
talking about every single people he's
talking about people's that have some
sort of you might call it warrior
tradition or some sort of aggressive or
protective relation of themselves the in
relation to the neighbor and he tells us
that Zarathustra has seen many lands and
many peoples perhaps you know thousands
of them and he's discovered the good and
the evil the gute and blues ax of many
peoples and then he says Zarathustra has
found no greater power on earth than
good and evil this valuation that we do
we set good over here we contrast evil
to it and perhaps evil in some cases
with this might have to be understood
not as the the traditional you know good
and evil as opposed to a previous
valuation of good and bad but perhaps
Nietzsche actually has this good and bad
valuation in mind and he tells us that
and this is a really great catchphrase
evaluation Jetson is creation
Safin values don't come down to us from
on high they are something that we as
human beings produce we create and now
we of course us late moderns come into a
world in which this process has been
going on for thousands of years so it's
not as if we are entering into a vacuum
and saying let's create some values
today we actually have a world that
perhaps has too many already tried out
schemes of values there but Nietzsche's
talking about how how it works with with
people's in some respect outside of
before before the state itself right
Phil Kerr and he sets out a kind of
story here he says man first implanted
values into things to maintain himself
he created the me
of things a human meaning and then he
calls himself man mensch the evaluator
right and he says evaluation is creation
valuing is itself the value and jewel of
created things so this is fundamental to
the human being this valuation this
holding dear is setting one thing above
another and saying this matters more
recognizing the goodness of something
and so he told us that only through
evaluation is there value and without
evaluation the nut of existence would be
Hollow this is this is integral to any
sort of meaning of life that human
beings have so he says a change in
values that means a change in the
creators of values he who has to be a
creator always has to destroy and then
he tells us at first it wasn't
individual human beings coming along and
saying here's the the values that you
need to recognize no they arose out of
people they arose out of the ways in
which human beings were associated
together
he says peoples were the creators at
first only later were individuals
creators and then he has a little aside
here indeed the individual himself is
the latest creation the individuals who
became creative did not think of
themselves solely as individuals the way
we late moderns would project back onto
them he says once the people hung a
table of values over themselves the love
that wants to rule and the love that
wants to obey created together such
tables as these and we're gonna come to
what a table of values is in just a
moment and then he says joy in the herd
is older than joy in the ego and as long
as the good conscience is called herd
only the bad conscience only the person
who's troubled says I now the creator's
and loving men he says created good and
evil individuals come along but first
they're loving people they're the people
who somehow rise out of the tribe the
herd the people the
whatever it happens to be and in some
respect they're not entirely free of it
they they stand out as heroes but they
stand out as heroes of this group later
he talks about loveless ego seeking
advantage in the advantage of many he
says that's not the origin of the herd
but the herds destruction that is when
we get something like a transvaluation
of values and things start to go
downhill so what else does teach what
else does need to have to teach us he
talks about every people having a table
of values and pathol does guter hanging
over them a thing a table a registry of
what it is that they hold to be valuable
what it is that they think is literally
good and he says that a table of values
is also a table of their overcoming
Zubaz indem a very important term not
only in the Spoke Zarathustra but for
Nietzsche's philosophy in general a
people is creative when it is engaging
in self overcoming but also overcoming
its environment also overcoming the
problems that it encounters figuring out
and carving out its place in the world
and then a little bit just right after
that he says it is the voice of its will
to power another key idea for Nietzsche
everything is driven ultimately by will
for power in his metaphysics what there
is a bit and this is found in people's
it doesn't follow exactly the same
trajectory in every case and this is why
Nietzsche says there's a thousand and
one different tables of values it's
determined in part by their responses to
things he says truly if you knew a
people's need
right and land in sky and neighbor you
could surely divine the law of their
over comings and why it is on this
ladder that it mounts towards its hope
so if we understand the conditions that
they came out of and in some cases this
may be quite difficult if there's no
historical record then we can understand
why they value what they do in fact
value and nature tells us a few things
that we can say our general
characteristics he says what do people
accounts hard
it calls praise worthy worthy of saying
look at this this is amazing right it
could be a musical composition it could
be bridging a river it could be
generating a great harvest and finding a
way to keep it from rotting
it could be dealing with the enemy that
is across that river and threatening to
come across and kill all of us and and
take our stuff it could be any thing
along these lines so what we account
hard we view as praiseworthy back then
what it accounts indispensable and hard
adding indispensability to that it calls
good and that which relieves the
greatest need the rare the hardest of
all it glorifies he says as the holy and
so we get a whole generation of values
coming out of responses to the problems
of life and the needs and as he says the
land and the sky the environmental
conditions and the neighbors he also
tells us that people's cannot have
exactly the same value right one
neighbor never understood another his
soul was always amazed at his neighbor's
madness and wickedness much that seemed
good to one person seem shame and
disgrace to another much that was called
evil in one place was decked with purple
honors why because they have different
sets of values so if you look at some of
the examples that he gives some of which
we can identify quite easily he says
here's here's four examples of these
values you should always be the first
and out rival all others you're jealous
soul should love no one except your
friend
this made the soul of a Greek tremble in
following it he followed the path to
greatness now is this everything about
the ancient Greeks no need to of course
is is giving us just one example of a
number of different possible Greek
moralities we could say but this is
something that you can see there in a
lot of ancient Greek literature and it
represents their ideals even down to the
time of you know the rise of Athens to
speak the truth and to know well how to
handle bow and arrow this seemed both
estimable and hard to that people from
whom I got my name what is that that is
the ancient Persians Zarathustra is the
you know sage who reforms the ancient
indo-iranian religion into what becomes
over a streon ism and you know according
to the Greeks those were the things that
the Persians held particularly dear
different set of values different table
than that of the ancient Greeks to honor
father and mother and to do their will
even from the roots of the soul another
people hung this table of overcoming
over itself and became mighty and
eternal with it who is he talking about
there perhaps the ancient Romans again
is that everything of ancient Rome and
their tables no but it is a different
path of life and then he says to
practice loyalty and for the sake of
loyalty to risk honor and blood even an
evil and dangerous causes another people
mastered itself with such teaching thus
mastering itself became pregnant and
heavy with great hopes who are we
talking about there perhaps the ancient
Germans or the Vikings or perhaps some
people in the Middle Ages when loyalty
was so highly valued it's not quite
clear who he's mentioning at that point
but what we have here are four of the
thousand and one possible ways of
arranging values of understanding
specifically what it would be to have
the praiseworthy the good
holy and so he tells us Zarathustra seen
many lands and many people he's found no
greater power on earth and the works of
these loving men and these are named
good and evil and then the question is
who is going through fast and Fedders
upon the thousand necks of these beasts
who is going to bring all of these
together the answer in another section
is the state but Nietzsche sees that is
a problem and then he suggests perhaps
the Superman that is one way of making
sense out of this cacophony of different
tables of values that comes from human
diversity and living in social matrices
you